let's go to the phone lines at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 many people wanting to get on
today let's start with our caller from
the 971 area code who is calling today
from 9 7 1 my name is Michael from the
Portland Oregon area hey Michael what's
going on hey man I just wanted to first
of all thanks a lot for taking my call I
just wanted to share my opinion on which
Democratic Canada has the best chance of
beating Trump okay and just so we
understand my beliefs my opinion is this
a qualitative or quantitative opinion I
guess it's just it's just simply my
opinion qualitative it's not based on
any kind of data in other words it's
based on your sense of what's going on
yes exactly
got it okay so I think that the country
the people of this country have been
looking for some sort of major shift and
major change and who it is that we elect
as President Obama was obviously the
first person that rally changed and a
lot of people got behind that and I
think that simply just carried over into
Donald Trump with people searching for
something outside of the standard
lifetime politician I was a huge
supporter last election donated to his
campaign multiple times but I don't even
for half a moment think that he has a
chance of winning real this go-around
yeah simply because he's I mean he's
been made to look like a radical to
anyone on the right there's always like
like a talking line that you know what
is the housewife in Kansas think about
such and such candidate and my wife's
family's from Kansas and I talked to a
lot of Kansas and Iowa people and it
just seems like you know Bernie Sanders
has been made this seem like a radical
plus with this heart attack I don't
his health was already a concern you
even you know I think his supporters now
let me just interject one thing here
Michael let's assume you're right and
that Bernie does not appeal to Kansas
housewives and thus he wouldn't win in
Kansas and let's assume he wouldn't win
against Trump in Iowa he doesn't need to
win in either of those states right so
it seems like that's maybe not part of
your analysis well I think part of it
too is just being able to sway voters
who may have you know vote voted for
Obama originally and then those who
shifted over to Trump
I don't think Bernie has the ability to
really shift them back over to voting
for a Democrat okay
and I getting to the candidate that I
think does I think the only candidate
that has a chance of doing that is Angie
oh boy
and why why do you think that he can't
seem to get past 3.5% nationally what do
you think is holding him back
if he is someone who is going to just
overwhelm voters with his policy and and
everything why is he getting more
support well I think it starts with has
to do a lot with the polling you know a
lot of people to answer poll phone calls
or elderly they're staying at home
they're pretty widely debunked Michael I
think you should take a look at the
methodology so now I do have to stop you
there was a poll from CNN from a while
ago that over sampled landlines but
we've done a deep dive into this and for
the most part the polls are adjusting
the sample on the basis of what
populations are empirically more likely
to vote and/or the portion of the
population that those popular that those
demographics represent so I think to
write off the polling is over sampling
elderly as the reason why Andrew yang
isn't doing well would be enough if
that's your argument then isn't Bernie
also probably doing better than the
polls say but you're saying Bernie has
no chance
well let me say obviously I'm wrong
because you pointed that out so thank
you for educating me on that I think
that's part of it I think
another part of the reason why Andrew
yang isn't pulling as well the same
reason why Bernie Sanders was employing
as well last election right like he
wasn't getting the airtime he wasn't
getting the fare questions you know when
they spoke to him they're asking kind of
ridiculous questions about Trump you see
the same kind of things happen it more
and more and readings that is getting
you know better questions about his
policy yeah but even despite that back
in 2016 even if I grant that Bernie was
not treated fairly in 2016 III agree
with you didn't he still get to polling
like 35 percent in the primary whereas
if we apply the same thing and reing
doesn't seem to be getting past three or
four percent I'm just trying to look at
the facts right I like Andrew yang I've
had him on the show I have no problem
with him personally but to say that it's
the same thing as with Bernie despite
all that Bernie still got too close to
40 percent in the Democratic primary
last time around right yeah no
absolutely but how many people were in
the field last time I don't know where
there's a different race listen Michael
I do I want to get on to some other
people but let me ask you this do you
think Andrea will ultimately be the
nominee
no you don't okay neither do I and I and
I don't think and I and it pains me to
say this and I felt this way last
election I said it so if Bernie Sanders
doesn't win the nomination for the
Democrats and Trump is going to win and
I think that way about and reing this
time I think if Andrew yang isn't the
one to go gets Trump I think the
Democrats are going to lose again all
right thank you so much for the call a
prediction that you are not alone in
making